got snl cast member eddie bryant on
scott give it up
so we are all used to skype zoom and
facetime these days if you're not then
you've been
really isolated um but we're even used
to all the technical issues that usually
come with it as well
like when i was talking to bones and
seal team actor david moriana's last
summer and this happened
i wish i i can't hear you but i wish i
could read lips but i can't i'll put
louie down
okay um navy seal
navy um navy no okay
this is like a game sounds like a shirt
okay
you play playing yes seal team
yes yes seal team
yep that was a lot of the interview
folks uh so now in honor of 80's show
shrill
on hulu it's time to put both our mics
on mute and play
the david borianis can't hear me game
i love you jesse uh how competitive do
you get on game nights 80 are you like
all in
i am the opposite where i'm like you win
i lose
oh my gosh well today i'm gonna really
go for it
we are we could not be more opposite
um so that's fine we're gonna be playing
for the audience so we're not going
against each other um this is i'm just
kidding
so this is a virtual version of the old
19th century game charades
80 and i take turns trying to get the
other to say a word or phrase while our
mics are muted
we're allowed to say the words use
motions and use props
um if we want to pass we hold up our
pass card
if we can get a total of eight words
correct in two rounds
everyone in the house seats will win a
prize so okay
mute my mic and i'll go first are you
ready
go oh i ice cream
ice cream cone yes
baby shark baby shark baby
um a beautiful hair a hair extension a
hair
oh brushing your teeth a toothbrush
um okay so eddy's giving the clues this
time
so mute her mic and let's go here we go
corn on the cob oh flossing flossing
dental floss
phone number calling phone call
answer the phone iphone iphone
[Music]
paper paper
cutting paper cutting paper cut paper
cut
staple staple paper stapling paper fudge
snapping paper paper clip paper clip
paper clip remote
we won we won we won we did it
um we are amazing so for game nights we
should be a team
all right we did it everybody in our
house seats is a winner
the globber eaton electric scooters are
equipped with high quality components
and smart features to deliver
safe and intuitive e-scooter rides
they're easy to use
user-friendly and have a built-in dual
braking system
in celebration of national scooter day
on may 19th
you're all getting a globber e10
electric scooter
uh thank you so much edie i love you so
much
season three of shrill is now streaming
on hulu everybody
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever